bene ma noi cosa facciamo sì bravissimo
[Musica]
ce ne vuoi andare forse con la fantasia
qualsiasi cosa vuoi creare cambiare i
numeri e le parole di colore
puoi fare valore
quello che non è viso mine
macché scuola divertente
è
[Musica]
le materie non si stancano
questo è il backstage della canzone
quindi voi che lo state vedendo avrete
già visto la canzone penso dove sono
tutti i bambini che hanno partecipato
nella cristiano alessandro e camilla
siamo contenti che stiamo compagni di
classe si piacerebbe se fossi mostra
consiglio aveva scola con poi dite che
mirarchi accettano di concreto non
troppo grande non so se ci cascano
tutto sembra nuove eccezioni
un 3 0 la classe più incasinato di tutti
questi sono tanti
vieni cosa avete foto vediamo chi se lo
ricorda
sono tutti carini uomo io ero una
compagna di banco la roma ieri abbiamo
fatto la battaglia ai marines femminile
fosse riprendono su provare dopo di te
posso farlo
lasciate sul mio canale il robot game
però 7 i griffin
si no
ma devo ancora nel backstage abbiamo
però ha cantato e ballato siete contenti
sì
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma vi rendete conto
tu l'hai preparo no kg a preparatissimo
hanno fatto 13 in verde non per me
ride
[Musica]
senza
si no
sì
[Applauso]
hanno sentito capitale io sono d'accordo
ma come mai scoperto su un bel piatto di
pasta le barriere
gli operai preparato il pinzimonio
leverò da immensi mario pizzi money
continente sono delle verdure tagliate
tipo tipo questo tipo la carota il
sedano peperoni pomodori e poi ci sarà
una ciotolina sale da concerto
[Musica]
no
quando ci vediamo
l'azione
grazie ringraziamo perché
importantissimo da maestra giudica è
stata bravissima e vicepreside giusto e
la vicepreside grazie mille per averci
concesso di filmare il video quando una
scuola che tra l'altro tutto ben la
stupenda questa scuola
se avrete un incremento di iscrizione
pari all istituto comprensivo di cena
istituto comprensivo di tutela primaria
si chiama anna frank
moresco maria anna frank grazie mille
grado a voi lo vedrà quello che non hai
visto mai
[Applauso]